von der leyen will riesige finanzspritze
750 milliarden euro sollen den
eu-ländern in der korona krise wieder
auf die beine helfen
lufthansa tritt auf die bremse wegen
möglicher auflagen aus brüssel schlägt
das unternehmen die angebotenen
staatshilfe erst einmal aus und
schockierendes video aus den usa ein
schwarzer amerikaner stimmt nach dem
brutalen einsatz eines weißen polizisten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch es ist der tag von
ursula von der leyen
sie muss alle eu mitglieder von ihren
plan zum wiederaufbau überzeugen bislang
gab es den deutsch-französischen
vorschlag 500 milliarden euro schulden
aufnehmen und an besonders betroffene
mitglieder verteilen
dagegen stemmten sich länder wie die
niederlande und österreich sie fordern
dass die hilfen zurückgezahlt werden
der plan der kommissionspräsidenten
jetzt ist eine mischung aus beidem
allerdings noch deutlich umfangreicher
zeigt julia schröter ein
konjunkturprogramm im wert von 750
milliarden euro
das ist der vorschlag von ursula von der
leyen 500 milliarden davon sollen als
zuschüsse an bedürftige eu länder gehen
das heißt das geld muss nicht
zurückgezahlt werden
250 milliarden sollen in form von
krediten fließen
sie sind also nur geliehen das geld
dafür will sich die eu am kapitalmarkt
leihen
es wäre das erste mal dass die eu
staaten gemeinsam schulden machen
die tilgung soll von allen gemeinsam
gestemmt werden und sie wird jahrzehnte
dauern
dieser wiederaufbauplan sei ein
hervorragendes signal aus brüssel sagen
die italiener die allerdings auch am
meisten davon profitieren würden andere
sehen das gigantische hilfspaket sehr
viel kritischer stefan leifert berichtet
wären da nicht diese ein meter fünfzig
abstandsregel viele hätten ihr wohl auf
die schulter geklopft im europaparlament
erntet ursula von der leyen für ihren
milliardenplan viel beifall für die
kritiker ist diese botschaft diejenigen
denjenigen die heute die mutige
investitionen scheuen
denen sage ich lasst uns morgen die
kosten des nichthandelns in dieser krise
viel viel teurer zu stehen kommen hier
geht es darum gemeinsam grundlagen für
unsere zukunft zu legen
profitieren sollen vom wiederaufbau plan
die am schwersten getroffenen
krisenländer italien bekäme demnach 173
milliarden euro spanien 140 auf
deutschland würden 29 milliarden
entfallen die schulden sollen über 30
jahre zurückgezahlt
das ist so sage ich das ganz deutlich
komplett irre der für diesen irrsinn von
den bürgern der union zu entrichtende
preis wird gigantisch sein wie werfen
mit dem geld nicht ihrem sondern dem der
steuerzahler nur so um sich als gäbe es
kein morgen aus spanien und italien
kommt beifall das signal aus brüssel sei
richtig sagt premier konnte fundamental
opposition weiterhin aus den
niederlanden heftig wickens wir haben
zusammen am wochenende mit dänemark
österreich und schweden einen anderen
ausgangspunkt vorgeschlagen wie wir uns
den wiederaufbau von vorstellen
in kombination mit einem modernen
haushalt und vor allem notwendigen
reformen in ländern die jetzt auf hilfe
angewiesen sind damit sie sich beim
nächsten mal dann selbst helfen können
wird es wirklich aufgenommen
bis das geld tatsächlich fließt wird
noch zeit vergehen von der leyen und den
eu regierungschefs stehen heftige kämpfe
um milliarden bevor an der klinik in
brüssel am anfang der pandemie gab es
große zweifel an der solidarität
innerhalb der eu ist das jetzt der
moment europas wie ursula von der leyen
es nennt der vorschlag von ursula von
der leyen ist tatsächlich eine art neue
erfindung der eu es ist der moment in
dem die mitgliedsstaaten zum ersten mal
der eu-kommission gestatten schulden am
finanzmarkt aufzunehmen und die diese
dann als zuschüsse an bedürftige länder
weiterzugeben
es ist eine neue etappe aber sie hat
erhebliche fragezeichen fragezeichen
nummer eins dieser neue wiederaufbau von
soll teil des siebenjährigen eu haushalt
seien für den von der leyen heute auch
einen vorschlag vorgelegt hat und zwar
genau den denen die staats und
regierungschefs im februar krachend
durchfallen ließen also da gibt es noch
sehr langwierige schwierige
verhandlungen und fragezeichen nummer
zwei ist wie sollen diese schulden
eigentlich zurückbezahlt werden da hat
von der leyen sich ein paar neue alte
europaweite steuern einfallen lassen
die digital steuer oder eine steuer auf
klimaschädliche produkte
die sind allesamt bei den
mitgliedstaaten so unpopulär dass es
ziemlich unwahrscheinlich ist dass sie
jemals wirklichkeit werden und für alles
was heute vorgeschlagen wurde gilt dass
alle sie
25 eu-mitgliedsstaaten einstimmig
zustimmen müssen
die einschätzung unserer brüssel
korrespondentin anne gellinek vielen
dank wir bleiben bei wirtschaftshilfen
die für die angeschlagene lufthansa
verzögern sich nämlich überraschend hat
der aufsichtsrat der airline die
entscheidung über das rettungspaket der
bundesregierung vertagt als grund nannte
er mögliche auflagen der eu-kommission
die will start und landerechte der
lufthansa an verschiedenen flughäfen
überprüfen
das hilfspaket besteht aus insgesamt
neun milliarden euro die bundesregierung
will sich mit zunächst 20 prozent an dem
unternehmen beteiligen
peter wagner in frankfurt die lufthansa
kann es sich doch gar nicht leisten auf
dieses rettungspaket zu verzichten warum
zögert der aufsichtsrat der aufsichtsrat
stellt sich quer weil es um sehr viel
geld geht und um diese harten auflagen
aus brüssel denn die neun milliarden aus
dem rettungspaket müssen mit zins und
zinseszins zurückgezahlt werden und
diese zinsen können bis auf neuneinhalb
prozent steigen und für seine stille
einlage im paket hat der bund eine
mindestrendite von 12 prozent festgelegt
egal wie schnell oder langsam sich das
geschäft mit dem fliegen erholt die
lufthansa wird teuer für ihre rettung
bezahlen müssen und da kommen diese
auflagen aus brüssel ins spiel angeblich
fordert die wettbewerbskommission dass
lufthansa bis zu 20 wertvolle
startrichter sogenannte slots hier in
frankfurt und in münchen an die
billigkonkurrenz von ryan air abgibt
dann entgeht uns ein dreistelliger
millionenbetrag im jahr an gewinn sagt
die lufthansa dazu also damit verstärkt
man den druck auf die verhandlungen
mit brüssel aber am ende über die
lufthansa zugeständnisse machen müssen
das geld reicht höchstens noch zwei
monate und ohne staatliche hilfen kann
die fluglinie nicht überleben
danke peter warten und jetzt zahlen die
große sorgen machen die politisch
motivierte kriminalität in deutschland
hat zugenommen und zwar deutlich
beispiel antisemitismus im vergangenen
jahr ist die zahl der jugend feindlichen
delikte um 13 prozent gestiegen auf mehr
als 2.000 der höchste wert seit
einführung der statistik vor fast 20
jahren die details jetzt von klaus
brodbeck solche erkenntnisse müssen in
den ministern sorgen machen
nicht nur weil immer mehr politisch
motivierte straftaten angezeigt werden
auch weil sich die gefahr dahinter
entwickelt die größte bedrohung ist nach
wie vor die bedrohung von rechts
wir haben das noch mal sehr intensiv bei
uns im hause und mit dem präsidenten
gesprochen
es ist eine neue dimension was die
bedrohung unserer demokratie an
der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
mutmaßlicher täter beide rechtsextremist
wie auch der attentäter von halle
zwei menschen starben das eigentliche
ziel die synagoge der stadt staat muss
hier schnell handeln muss zügig zu
verurteilungen kommen und es braucht
mehr zuständige die für antisemitische
straftaten auch spezifisch die
verantwortung tragen damit dass in den
sicherheitsbehörden und bei der justiz
nicht untergeht immer weiter warnen
ermittler versuchten rechtspopulisten
und rechtsextreme in die mitte der
gesellschaft vorzudringen
die afb weist den verdacht
antisemitismus zu begünstigen zurück wir
haben was sozusagen antisemitismus und
die ganze problematik angeht überhaupt
kein nachholbedarf wenn sich die anträge
angucken die im bundestag gestellt
werden
gegen antisemitismus oder verfolgung von
sozusagen jüdischen interessen der
jüdischen menschen in der welt dann
haben wir die entsprechende anträge
gebracht sicherheitspolitiker und
behörden warnen aber vor einer verrohung
der gesellschaft auch sprachlich
attentäter wie der von halle würden
dadurch ermutigt gibt es rechtsextreme
netzwerke im ksk der elitetruppe der
bundeswehr nach mehreren extremismus
fällen soll dass eine arbeitsgruppe
klären einberufen von
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer
ziel ist es radikale schneller zu
entdecken und nachhaltiger gegen sie
vorgehen zu können
zuletzt war ein ksk soldat festgenommen
worden der plastik sprengstoff und
munition gehortet hatte im kampf gegen
korona gehen die bundesländer eigene
wege im prinzip ok meint die kanzlerin
mahnt aber trotzdem auch künftig
gemeinsames vorgehen an
nach einer konferenz mit den ost
ministerpräsidenten sagte merkel ihr als
bundeskanzlerin und der ganzen regierung
sei es schon wichtig in grundsätzlichen
fragen übereinstimmung zu haben konkret
nannte sie den mindestabstand und den
mund nasenschutz im öffentlichen raum
und jetzt der blick auf die korona
fallzahlen in deutschland im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 490 menschen pro tag
angesteckt insgesamt wurden mehr als
181.000 500 fälle durch tests bestätigt
knapp 163.000 erkrankte gelten als
genesen 8400 16 menschen sind in
verbindung mit coop 19 gestorben
infizieren sich kinder weniger leicht
mit dem corona virus als erwachsene
ganz sicher ist das nicht aber vieles
deutet darauf hin für baden württemberg
ist das ein grund ab ende juni kitas und
grundschulen zu öffnen
auch weil der druck von eltern und
ärzten wächst eva schiller
kinder leiden leiser aber die letzten
wochen haben spuren hinterlassen
paul zieht sich oft zurück arthur ein
kind mit förderbedarf hat
bewegungsabläufe verlernt die ja längst
konnte ihre mutter hat die wut
zusammengeschweißt sie haben von baden
württemberg aus eine bundesweite
initiative gegründet 80.000
unterschriften gesammelt weil sie finden
dass kinder in der lockerung diskussion
zu kurz kommen
man merkt einfach sehr sehr deutlich
dass der stellenwert von kindern und
familie bei uns eine gesellschaft nicht
der ist der eigentlich sein sollte
dänemark und norwegen haben als erstes
geöffnet die aber auch alles runter
gefahren mitte april haben sich die
kitas und die grundschulen wieder
aufgemacht bei uns wird alles andere
zuerst aufgemacht und dann fängt man an
zu überlegen ob man kitas und
grundschulen vielleicht mal wieder ein
bisschen öffnen könnte der druck zeigt
offenbar wirkung auf der konferenz der
familienminister präsentiert baden
württemberg seinen sonderweg das land
hat bei vier unikliniken eine kinder
studie in auftrag gegeben
erst der erkenntnisse die nur der
regierung vorliegen deuten darauf hin
dass kinder sich viel seltener
infizieren als erwachsene da haben wir
für die anderen länder gute arbeit
geleistet jetzt wissen wir in etwa wir
haben ein gespür in welchem äußeren und
gefährdungs rahmen wir es tun können und
das verleiten auch mehr
handlungssicherheit belastbare zahlen
fehlen zwar noch trotzdem will
ministerpräsident kretschmann ende juni
kindergärten komplett öffnen
ihm genügt der trend der studie wir
können damit ausschließen dass kinder
besondere treiber des aktuell
infektionsgeschehen darstellen bei
diesem virus
kinder sind keine viren schleudern
sondern die zukunft sagen die
gründerinnen der elterninitiative
sie müssten ihr recht auf bildung
zurückbekommen
busunternehmer haben in mehreren städten
für mehr staatliche unterstützung in der
korona krise demonstriert und gefordert
wieder loslegen zu dürfen
allein nach berlin kamen hunderte busse
und zahlreiche mitarbeiter der
touristikbranche viele firmen stehen
nach eigenen angaben vor dem aus die
bundesregierung will den reisebus
unternehmen mit insgesamt 170 millionen
euro helfen
als teil des kommenden konjunkturpakets
niemand lebt schon so lange unter corona
bedingungen wie die chinesen die
pandemie hat das land verändert nicht
nur weil die wirtschaft in die knie
gegangen ist viele menschen sind
verunsichert blicken in eine ungewisse
zukunft
unser korrespondent ulf röller ist durch
das riesenland gereist und hat eindrücke
aus erster hand gesammelt
die berge heißen gipfel des kaiserlichen
pinsels oder tor des südlichen himmels
der nationalpark in der provinz hunan
jeder chinese möchte hier einmal urlaub
machen
doch wegen der korona krise dürfen
reisegruppen nicht kommen
vor dem haupteingang zum tag wimmelt es
normalerweise von touristen jetzt ist
der platz menschenleer
reiseleiterin forscher fürchtet um ihre
existenz wie millionen chinesen
wir wissen nicht was wir machen sollen
um ehrlich zu sein wir haben alle eine
schlechte schulausbildung die
anforderungen für einen guten job sind
besonders hat es ist eine reise mit
vielen hindernissen ständig werden wir
kontrolliert oder von der polizei
verfolgt china will keinen unzensierten
blick auf seine wirtschaftskrise
denn an der ostküste am hafen von ingo
stapeln sich die container im süden in
der stadt dongguan haben die tausenden
kleinen fabriken nicht mehr viel zu tun
denn die welt bestellt keine waren
werden als in china die epidemie
ausbrach galten unsere produkte als
vergiftet niemand wollte mehr made in
china kaufen bis an die russisch
chinesische grenze bringt uns unsere
reise eine wichtige handelsroute auch
hier spüren wir die krise selbst in den
entlegensten gegenden des landes hat das
virus das leben verändert
die doku inside china können sie um 22
uhr 15 sehen oder jederzeit in der zdf
mediathek in hongkong ist die polizei
massiv gegen demonstranten vorgegangen
die gegen das von china geplante
sogenannte sicherheitsgesetz protestiert
haben
etwa 300 menschen wurden festgenommen
die kürzlich vorgelegten pläne der
regierung in peking haben die
massenproteste in der
sonderverwaltungszone hongkong wieder
belebt mit dem neuen gesetz könnten
chinesische polizei und geheimdienste
nach hongkong verlegt werden und gegen
die protestbewegung vorgehen in die usa
da ärgert sich präsident trump über den
faktencheck seines lieblings mediums
twitter und droht mit der schließung
sozialer medien twitter hatte erstmals
die inhalte zweier trump tweets als
falsch gekennzeichnet er hatte briefwahl
mit wahlbetrug und manipulation
gleichgesetzt briefwahl wird wegen
corona als alternative für die
präsidentenwahl im november diskutiert
trump witterte der faktencheck sei wahl
einmischung und unterdrückung freier
meinungsäußerung
der eklat zwischen donald trump und
twitter alle details dazu haben wir
online für sie zum nachlesen wie
faktenchecks in sozialen netzwerke
funktionieren und wie die plattformen
gegen fake news kämpfen in der zdf-
heute- app in den usa ist auch wieder
eine debatte über rassistische
polizeigewalt entbrannt weiße polizisten
haben einen schwarzen verdächtigen in
minneapolis so lange zu boden gedrückt
bis er das bewusstsein verlor und später
starb
es ist der dritte fall dieser art
innerhalb weniger wochen
es dürfe kein todesurteil sein eine
schwarze hautfarbe zu haben sagt der
bürgermeister von minneapolis ines trams
berichtet fünf lange minuten hat der
weiße polizist sein knie auf dem hals
des afroamerikaners verdächtigt hatten
sie ihn der geldwäscherei die festnahme
brutal er wimmert wird immer
regungsloser umstehende protestieren
er reagiert nicht mehr fühlt seinen puls
rufen sie der 46 jährige george floyd
aus minneapolis ein weiteres opfer von
polizeigewalt gegen schwarze im
krankenhaus wird sein tod festgestellt
vier beamte werden entlassen
fünf minuten seufzt der bewegte
bürgermeister von minneapolis wenn man
jemand um hilfe schreien hört muss man
doch helfen diese beamten haben versagt
versagt menschlich zu sein
dieses mal reagieren die behörden rasch
auch weil es protest gibt von politikern
und auf der straße in minneapolis
eskalieren die demonstrationen
kurzzeitig das handy-video der festnahme
es sorgt für wut und entsetzen
jeder soll das sehen welt schau dir das
an die festnahme von montag die dann aus
dem ruder lief anfangs hatte der
polizei-chef seine beamten noch in
schutz genommen nun soll das fbi
ermitteln die familie klagt an
er hat geschrien mama ich kann nicht
mehr atmen sie haben ihn umgebracht
schlimmer als ein tier haben sie ihn
behandelt sein leben haben sie genommen
nun sollen sie lebenslang kriegen ende
eines einsatzes ein handy video belegt
weiße polizeigewalt gegen schwarze
wieder einmal
und auch noch das aus den usa seit 2011
sind keine amerikaner mehr in einer us
rakete ins all geflogen sondern immer in
russischen raketen in gut drei stunden
soll sich das ändern
vorausgesetzt das wetter macht mit der
countdown läuft dass die usa wieder von
cape canaveral in florida astronauten
zur internationalen raumstation schicken
die rakete vom typ falcon 1 kommt nicht
von der nasa sondern von privaten
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex seit acht
jahren schon übernimmt die firma des
milliardärs elon musk versorgungsflüge
zur iss
fehlen noch die lottozahlen
sie lauten 4 25 36 39 43 47 und die
superzahl 3 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157 von der natur
dringend gebraucht morgen verträgen
allerdings längst nicht überall wo genau
wie viel weiß gleich katja honnefer
claus kleber begrüßt sie um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal dankeschön für ihr
interesse
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren jetzt
kommt ein bisschen bewegung ins wetter
und das liegt an einer kleinen kaltfront
die brachte heute von der nordsee schon
die ersten wolken und sie beschäftigt
uns auch noch in der nacht und morgen
über tag jetzt heute nacht wird sie
liegen hier ungefähr zwischen der neiße
und dem saarland und deswegen liegen
dort die temperaturen zwischen 12 und 8
grad deutlich kälter wird es in der
lüneburger heide oder auch am alpenrand
mit vier oder sechs grad denn dort wird
es sternenklar sein
mit dieser kaltfront regen heran und vor
allen dingen in sachsen können durchaus
in dieser nacht so fünf bis 20 liter
regen pro quadratmeter fallen
die kaltfront erreicht am morgen auch
den alpenrand da sind dann auch einige
gewitter möglich und von polen ziehen
einige regenschauer zu uns rein sonst
wechseln sonne und wolken miteinander ab
und zwischen nordfriesland und dem
saarland scheint die sonne strahlt in
der nähe der küste und in dieser schau
luft und unter den regenwolken bleibt es
morgen bei 15 bis 18 grad recht kühl
sonst werden im binnenland 19 bis 24
grad erreicht
und ganz ähnlich geht es in den nächsten
tagen weiter im südosten ist es eher mal
stärker bewölkt kann auch vielleicht mal
regnen sonst aber scheint häufig die
sonne bei temperaturen von 14 bis 24
grad
schönen abend noch